Đây là con hát ý khai.
Nó là ua về tích hợp về tổng ở ai từ đồng tìm mà dật.
Hát ý xai nặng khoảng 50,000 đồng cơm.
Lạc tốc độ tối đả ba trăm năm 2019.
Thời dân phai khoảng 40,000 đồng cơm và phạm vi hạng động tối đả 1,000 chilong bếp.
UV được 10,5 mạng để thu nhận người nắn hỗ trợ dựng giĩnh và 3,5 mụ tíu.
Ở trí đồng từ đồng, hát ý xai có thể tử tìm kiến khoam theo và lắm trạng UV đã được sức lần.
Thích bế cũng có thể chuyển sạch tế đầu điều chuyển từ ra.
Mình sẽ ngắm, cái đầu thì trường rất là một nụ tế ở đây tổng trạng.
Mình sẽ ngắm và sau khi bắt được nụ tế, mình sẽ có có.
Bây lên mà nó tìm mụ tế ở và nó tế, hàng kéo đó.
UV cho việc đầm đi quốc, sản xuất làm chữ một số có phần UV mềm và bó hạng.
Đồng cơ và chịp hiện hưởng được nhập hấu.
Súng trong UV hát xai gây tự ý với tích kế nhỏ gọn.
Cơ động có thể mang phát và xuy dụng trong gì để quốc.
Hát xai là một trong số UV lượng dụng được nhất hiểu tại bố thào dịt các hổng phân tế UV,
cho các nhạm qua hậm truyền gia và trân nghiệp thụ khỏi hàng không vụ tụi tích nằm và sạch
đi bú, thi kế và tế đạo.
Trong đó, hát xấu có thể nằm mang theo 2 UV và thả được đen không để thực hiện givồn.
Hát x năm, được thi kế để phẩm chuyến, thả hạn và thi tế như vẩm tại các khu vật bị chi cắt có tìm cần.